before i go into an explanation of why
housing prices
skyrocketed from 2000 to 2006 i i think
it's a good idea to give a little
history of what the housing market and
the mortgage market used to be like uh
before things got out of control so
let's go back to say i don't know let's
go back to um the late 70s uh maybe mid
70s actually i remember my parents they
bought a house we lived in new orleans
and and the house if i remember
correctly it cost roughly 60 thousand
dollars
sixty thousand dollars and back then to
buy a house uh and actually for a while
until more recently in order to buy a
house you have to put twenty five
percent down so twenty five percent of
sixty thousand dollars is the fourth of
its you have to put fifteen thousand
dollars down
you have to save up fifteen thousand
dollars and then you're going to get a
mortgage on forty five thousand dollars
right forty five thousand you're going
to borrow and i forgot the exact
interest rates then but i'm just going
to throw out a number just to this is
really just to kind of for instructive
purposes let's say interest rates back
then they were higher they were like
nine percent i think
so 49 on 45 000 how much interest am i
going to pay
45 123
times 0.09
so i'm going to pay
a little over four thousand dollars
a year in interest
or if i divide by 12
about 340 dollars a month
three hundred and forty dollars
per month
in interest
and i remember at the time we we
actually moved out of our house and we
rented it out because we needed cash and
we rented out that exact same house and
i this was in the late 70s or early
early 80s we rented out that exact same
house for nine hundred dollars
the rent
was nine hundred dollars
so this this this raises
i guess a couple of questions uh first
of all the big question is why are those
why did those people who
who rented our house i mean they paid
900 a month they must have had a good
income and i mean for that time
why were they willing to pay rent when
they could have bought a house where the
mortgage would have been you know would
have been interest plus a little
principal it would have been no more
than 400 a month you know why would and
so why would you just throw away you
know this is a classic rent versus buy
argument why would you throw away 900
where you could actually build equity
paying 400 a month for the exact same
place
and you can think about that a little
bit but there's a bunch of reasons
what what was necessary to buy a house
then
well one you needed a fifteen thousand
dollars down payment
maybe these people they had really good
cash flow every month but they just
never had uh
the circumstances or maybe it's even the
discipline to save up fifteen thousand
dollars
you also needed a really steady job so
you need this is the down payment this
is one thing you also need a steady job
steady job
maybe the people who are renting had uh
you know they were working odd jobs or
they were they didn't have a steady
income although i doubt it i don't think
we would have actually leased the house
to them had that been the case but they
probably had that
they probably
and so and then the last thing you
needed to get a mortgage is you needed a
good credit
and maybe these people didn't have that
maybe they just you know they didn't pay
some bills in the past and they just
they couldn't find a bank that was
willing to give them a loan despite
having a steady job and a fifteen
thousand dollar down if you had to ask
me i think the biggest barrier for for
this family at that time was probably
the fifteen thousand dollar down payment
and frankly they probably had trouble
saving fifteen thousand dollars because
they were paying
they were busy paying nine hundred
dollars in rent so that was the
circumstance
throughout actually most of
modern history that you had this barrier
towards buying a house that it did make
sense that you know the conventional
wisdom that it is better to
buy than rent held is just
everyone knew that but a lot of people
just couldn't buy even though they
wanted to because they didn't have the
down payment they didn't have the steady
job or they didn't have the good credit
that was the circumstance then and that
lasted for some time
what happened in the early 2000s and it
actually happened in california in the
mid-90s but it got more and more
i guess we could say flagrant as we went
through the decade
is that people started lowering these
standards and i'll do a whole other
video on possibly why those standards
were lowered but let's say that in 1980
you needed 25 percent down
you need let me just switch colors that
color is kind of ugly
you need a steady job
steady job
and you needed a i don't know let's say
you need a 700 credit score
and that was true from 1980 to let's say
2000. i'm exaggerating a bit but this is
just to give you the broad sense of what
actually happened but let's say then in
2001 and i'll explain later why this
might have happened the standards were
lowered that if you wanted to buy a
house all of a sudden you could actually
find someone who's willing to give you a
house for 10 down
10 down
you know maybe kind of steady job
kind of steady job maybe just need a job
and maybe have a 600 credit rating
so what happens when the standards on
the mortgage go from this to this
let's go back to these people who used
to rent that house from us for nine
hundred dollars
maybe they didn't have fifteen thousand
dollars right that would have been a
twenty-five percent down payment but
maybe back then they had ten percent
maybe they had six thousand dollars they
just couldn't get up to fifteen thousand
dollars in savings so if in 19 you know
back when they were doing this back in
the 80s if if the standards
got a little bit freer like they did in
in the early 2000s those people could
have bought a house they would have said
man you know we don't have to rent
anymore we've saved up the 10 down
payment it's gotten a little easier our
job now meets the requirements our
credit now meets the requirements we can
go buy that house so that would have
increased the aggregate demand for
housing even though
even if no one's incomes increased even
if the population didn't increase all of
a sudden there's a new person who could
get financing to buy a house
and then if we go to
2000 and
2000 let's say 2003 they say you know
what you don't even you don't need any
down payment no down
no money down
so that's a you can imagine there's a
whole set of people who maybe had a
decent income but they couldn't save any
money now all of a sudden there's
there's no down payment barrier to
buying a house maybe you still needed a
job
and maybe just needed a 500 credit right
so all of a sudden without people's
incomes going up without more jobs being
available without
the population increase there were more
people who could get financing or more
people who could bid up homes and this
situation actually got pretty bad by
2004 2005 and this isn't exact but it
gives you a sense of what happened by
2004-2005
you had you had a situation where they
had these stated income they had these
things called liar loans and maybe i'll
do videos on each of these but these
were essentially no down payment
if you had a job you could kind of make
it up you you said i had a job they
wouldn't validate it these were stated
income then you could say you could just
say what you made so even though the
mortgage might you know require an
income of ten thousand dollars a month
and your income is only two thousand a
month you could say your income is ten
thousand a month so you know stated
income no down
maybe a job
and they didn't even do a credit check
so what happened from 2000 to 2004 is
that credit just got easier and easier
and easier and every time credit got
easier there were more people who
despite the fact that they weren't
making any more money
they were able to get financing and so
the the pool of people who were able to
bid on homes or the demand for homes
because now there was this financing
became larger and larger and that's what
increased the prices of homes and now
you know you
the obvious question is well why did
this happen what well you know first of
all why did they get easier in 2001 get
easier and easier as we went to 2004 and
why did they get to this
unbelievably absurd level where by 2004
and 2005 you you hear stories especially
in california in florida of people who
are making maybe 40 000 a year and they
were able to buy houses with no money
down um with you know some of these
people were migrant laborers and they
were able to buy houses for four million
dollars
so and so in the next video i will tell
you why that happened why were people
willing to give their cash um
to people to buy a house that had a very
low likelihood of getting paid back and
for a house that had a very um low
likely of hood of being able to retain
its value i'll see you in the next
video you